a very good morning to you
mr scully uh when we have
armed forces at the capitol's hospitals
as being described as the nhs on a war
footing we've got a pretty serious
problem
well we know there's uh pressures on the
nhs and that's why we went into plan b
before christmas uh and we are we
started off in a better position than we
were this time last year not just
because
there is a bigger disconnect between
hospitalizations and case numbers but
also because we started the process the
the year with 3 000 more doctors 10 000
more nurses than we did this time last
year but but you're absolutely right
there are pressures on
staff uh presences and
people being absent and that's why we
put into place uh things like the
digital staff passport so people can
move around staff can move around
hospitals far easier the fact that we've
brought in the military
as you say to be able to support nhs
staff because we want to make sure that
uh that people can get through this pro
this period in time of particular
pressure on the nhs as best but this
isn't normal though is it as we learned
today
this isn't normal though is it no
clearly excited it's not no absolutely
hospitals is not normal and the mod says
that there's going to be more more
troops being deployed expected to go to
the north of england next so there's
more to come
yeah it is i mean when you talk about
armed forces you know around hospitals
they're not sitting there in combat or
anything like that it's it's more people
helping out helping out the undoubted
pressures on the nhs and that's why we
want people to get out and get
vaccinated and get boosted to make
because that's remains our best weapon
against the pressures on the nhs and
against covid as we learned to live with
covid
more restrictions being called for by
medics by the nhs to avoid situations of
having armed forces in hospitals are
they still totally off the table
this this at the moment we're looking at
the data but we've seen what's happening
in london which was leading the way in
the in the curve on
the case numbers and we we don't see uh
the need to do it at this moment in time
we'll clearly be reviewing our plan b uh
scenario before the 26th of january and
then we'll come to parliament with uh
with the decisions that's been taken at
that time but what you find is that any
plans and any restrictions that come in
take weeks to get through the uh the
process of being infected with
the virus and then hospitalizations and
unfortunately deaths so what we're doing
now is something that will affect the
numbers in the nhs in a few weeks time
that's why we're looking at the curve
and the data on a day-to-day basis
i'm wondering how united the government
is on this particularly at senior levels
reports in the papers today that the
health secretary um has been saying that
uh due to the loosening of travel
restrictions which we're seeing from
today that we could see more lockdowns
what's your view
well i don't believe at this stage we we
need any more lockdowns we what we're
doing today is we're announcing the the
uh the fact that the money for
hospitality retail and leisure and
accommodation uh is available now for
those businesses that have been hardest
uh pressed throughout this this pandemic
and especially over that christmas
period when plan b came in for those
businesses to be able to approach their
local authorities to get the financial
support they need but what we've got to
do is we've got to make sure that we can
balance um the needs of of everybody
within what is an incredibly difficult
situation the pressures on the nhs but
also the pressures on the economy the
pressures on households jobs livelihoods
and indeed money that's coming in to pay
for the public services in the first
place
yeah you're talking about livelihoods
there i know you are the small business
minister here you're here to talk to us
of course about business it's very quiet
out there isn't it um it's a very low
footfall in december was the guidance of
work from home a mistake
i think it's the it's the right thing to
do to make sure that people remember
that they have choices uh
they need the flexibility to be able to
not get on the commute uh uh necessarily
be standing so close to people despite
the fact that uh you know obviously in
in london underground and other uh and
and trains around the country and buses
people should be wearing masks but
nonetheless if we're just disconnecting
people in those sort of ways that helps
reduce the numbers of of cases although
as i say the case numbers are in
themselves are not the the sole measure
because there is a bigger disconnect now
between the case numbers and the
hospitalization thanks to the
vaccination program and thanks to the
booster program
are you thinking about reversing that
guidance about work from home because
businesses are suffering
well i think what we've said is that we
we're sticking to plan b at the moment
the 26th of uh of january is the date
for the review of that so we'll look at
what what the data is saying that uh at
that um in the lead up to that to that
date but clearly we've got to get that
difficult balance right and that's
taking the views of those businesses
taking the views of the the of the
scientists and then making a judgment
call
with parliament fully involved
i know that you're coming on the program
because you're announcing funding today
some support for businesses some covid's
support it looks very much like what you
announced on the 21st of december what
is new today
no it is exactly the it is exactly that
program what i'm saying today is that
that money is hitting the local
authorities now
it's for businesses now too that are in
the hospitality
retail and leisure to approach the local
authorities to make sure that they can
get that money quickly it is available
for them we want to make sure that we
can get the money to them
now while it's needed rather than
letting it drag on for for a few weeks
because we know that cash flow i used to
run small businesses for 25 years i know
cash flow is absolutely everything
especially a pressured point like this
so any businesses that are affected in
those in those sectors please do
approach your local authority
you talk empathetically mr scully about
uh cash flow we saw some fiery exchanges
um in pmqs on wednesday um is this a
government that takes the cost of living
crisis seriously because some people
would would say that perhaps the prime
minister's response on that would
suggest otherwise
we take it really seriously i mean we
know that the uh
you know energy prices are are an issue
that uh that the people are worried
about um uh a cost of living in general
that's why we announced the biggest cash
increase in the national living wage um
since its inception uh
to to kick in um in in april that's why
we uh got rid of the ill changed the
taper for universe personal credit which
puts a thousand pounds uh back into the
pockets of the lowest paid as well so
we're trying to make these targeted uh
approaches whether it's the warm homes
disc out the window at the same time
forgive me for interrupting forgive me
for interrupting mr scully we do have
this looming massive hike in energy
bills what is the government going to do
about that
well we're work we speak to uh the uh
energy companies themselves with off gem
uh on on a regular basis we've been
doing that right away through christmas
and new year to really see see what we
can do
with this global
surge in energy prices long term clearly
we need to make sure that we get rid of
the fluctuations uh and the prices of
fossil fuels by bringing in more
renewables but there is this immediate
issue that you rightly describe about
energy prices and we're working with
energy companies and off gem to see what
more we can do
well a talk takes a while doesn't it and
uh implementation also takes a while
so it doesn't sound like you've got any
plans to immediately address there's
massive jumping bills that people are
going to be seeing very soon
well what we've got is we've got the
targeted approach uh the to to
help with fuel bills for the lowest paid
in particular so the winter fuel
payments the uh uh the the uh warm homes
discount that target millions of of the
lowest paid households across the
country to try and ease their bills but
but clearly we'll make sure that we're
working as i say with the energy
companies to see what more we can do
with those bills in the first place i
think a lot of people worried about
their energy bills aren't going to be
satisfied with that answer mr scully but
let's move on is it the right time to be
raising national insurance contributions
because some people in your cabinet
would say not
well we know that uh you we've talked
about the pressures on the nhs so uh
that that that um
levy will initially go to uh to uh
easing the pressures on the nhs but
clearly tackling that long-term issue of
social care which has yet been untouched
because it's been so difficult to
resolve but this is a progressive tax it
means that the um
the top 14 percent of earners will pay
about half of the entire levy um and so
it is a progressive tax that means that
um if you if you earn more you will pay
more and contribute more to that
difficult and tractable problem about
social care
mr scully some people will say that the
conservative party is way out of touch
on the cost of living uh just the way
people need to live their lives pay to
put food on the table i'm just wondering
um how in touch you are with all of this
and can you tell us what the national
minimum wage is for example and the
price of a pint of milk
well that's one million wages eight
pound 91 is going up to nine pound fifty
that's that that sits with me and i
don't find my milk in pints these days i
tend to buy the the four point um
larger roughly larger um
uh uh cut cartons but you know this is
this isn't about um
how much is that when you go and buy the
lard
it's about demonstrating to the public
that you are a government that
understands the cost of living and the
pressures on people's budgets
sam what it's about is it it's it's
about making sure that we have a a
massive pandemic as you as you unwind
that pandemic you get into the uh uh the
the global situations of supply chains
of of energy costs affecting not just
people in britain but people around the
world we've got to make sure that we
look after people within this country
what we're doing is we're targeting the
uh in particular
forgive me for interrupting you have you
have made that point but while we are on
the cost of living and whether the
conservative party understands the
pressures that people face um the prime
minister recent texts revealing uh he's
asking as we know about this already
lord brownlow for more than a hundred
thousand pounds to do up the tip as he
as he describes it that he is living in
that strikes me as a party that is out
of touch
no no the the prime minister in terms of
the uh the issue around the flat has uh
put up an apology to lord guy about the
the way the process uh worked in his
uh we want to make sure that actually we
are tackling the day-to-day for them
especially the lowest paid but not just
the lowest paid the people that are
pressed in in
mid-learners as well because we're all
going through increases in energy costs
we're all um seeing the increase in
supplies whether it's building work
whether it's uh just home improvements
and uh
and all those day-to-day things that the
people having as well and food costs
all right paul scully thank you very
much for your time this morning on sky
news